Democrats have made a massive dump of
Iowa as the first vote in the 2024
primary I think this is very interesting
and quite frankly I'm in favor of it and
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about why Reuters has a good explainer
very very straightforward what's going
on Democrats approve Biden's revamped
primary calendar the DNC on Saturday
approved a shake-up of the 2024 primary
calendar giving black voters a greater
say in the nominating process and
carving an easier path for Biden's
expected re-election bid
the party's vote Saturday replaces the
famed Iowa caucuses as the first in the
nation with South Carolina a state with
significantly more black voters and one
that saved Biden's 2020 presidential
campaign it would be followed by New
Hampshire and Nevada one week later than
by Georgia and Michigan now we've talked
about this for a while now the this is
happening at what is arguably a
politically fraught time because I've
been saying we need to do something like
this for multiple election Cycles why is
Iowa first Iowa is 90 percent white it's
extraordinarily rural it's not
representative of anything about the
Democratic party or voters in general or
preferences for candidates it just gets
a lot of attention because it's first
and why is it first it's not really
clear that it should be so for a very
long time I've been saying South
Carolina is not a bad choice racially
South Carolina is very much more aligned
with a national demographics you know
Iowa's 90 white South Carolina's 69
percent white that is much closer to the
U.S population you could look at other
demographics you could say well how what
about education what about age what
about you can always pick and say this
state is more representative in this way
but that state is more representative
okay we could do that
one thing is for sure
Iowa is neither representative nor
should it be first every time around so
we floated different ideas over time
what about a different order every
election cycle it could be randomized so
one year it's one state that goes first
one year it's another or picking
particular States I think South Carolina
is a fine state to go first I think
moving on to New Hampshire Nevada
Georgia Michigan these are certainly
more representative States in many ways
than Iowa the reason this is now
becoming particularly contentious is
that you might remember that in 2020
South Carolina saved Joe Biden Joe Biden
was not doing particularly well in those
early primaries now you could say well
he wasn't doing well but those were
early primaries not representative of
the national Democratic electorate
that'd be one perspective so you could
say it made sense that when you got to a
more representative State like South
Carolina
Biden did well and then he went on to
win the Counterpoint to that is that the
South Carolina situation was very much
stage managed to deny Bernie the
nomination
um and to uh get Joe Biden
um uh the electoral votes that uh he he
very not the uh delegate votes delegate
numbers that he needed and you might
remember that uh James Clyburn came out
and uh endorsed and strongly supported
Joe Biden followed by a number of other
candidates including Pete boot Edge who
dropped out at a time that was very
convenient for Joe Biden so although
this would make sense any year this
particular election cycle it really does
seem pointed at helping Joe Biden who
has not yet announced his re-election
campaign but is indeed expected to let
me know your thoughts does this make
sense because it makes sense does it
make less sense because it specifically
is likely to help Biden what do you
think make sure that you weigh in which
you can do on our Instagram by finding
us at David packman show or of course on
the YouTube channel which exploded after
I came to you with tears in my eyes for
help at the end of January added almost
000 new YouTube subscribers in January
make sure you are one of the 1.6 closing
in on 1.7 million we'll take a quick
break and be right back
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zipx brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below